the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or to view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
okay guys we're actually slightly ahead
of where I thought we'd be at this point
so I'm only gonna spend about half of
today's lecture finishing up some new
material on mass parabolas and stability
I also got a comment in through the
anonymous box that said please leave a
little bit of time after class for
questions so you can get them out right
away and because I'm usually running off
the teach some other class at like the
IDC or some other building so from now
on I'll try and leave about five minutes
at the end of class for questions on
today's material and we'll make up with
it with the second half hour or 25
minutes of this class being for all the
questions on the material so far in the
first two weeks but first I wanted to
give a quick review of where we were
Wednesday and launch back into math
parabolas which are ways of looking at
nuclear stability in relative numbers
and even or oddness of nuclei so you saw
last time we intuitively derived the
semi empirical mass formula as a sum of
volume surface Coulomb asymmetry and
pairing or whether things are even even
or odd even terms with the coefficients
in MeV gleaned from data and the forms
of the and the exponents right here
gleaned from intuition here we assume
that the nucleus can be thought of like
a big drop of liquid with some charged
particles in it and so the droplet
should become more stable the more
nuclei there are or the nor nucleons
there are but then you have some more
outside on the surface that aren't
bonded to the others all of the protons
are repelling each other over linear
length scales because the radius of this
liquid drop would scale like a to the
one third there's an asymmetry term
which means if the neutrons and protons
are out of balance there's going to be
some some less binding energy and then
there's this extra part that tells you
whether the nuclei are even even or odd
odd and this works pretty well if you
remember we looked at theory versus
experiment where all the red points here
are theoretical predictions and all the
black points are experimental
predictions and for the most part they
look spot-on it generates the classic
binding energy per nucleon curve that
you see in the textbook and can predict
from the semi empirical mass formula
zooming in and correcting for let's say
just getting absolute values of errors
you can see that except for the very
small nuclei and a few Peaks which we
explained by looking even closer the
formula well it predicts nuclear
stability quite well on average again
this line right here if there's a dot
that lies on this blue line it means
that theory and experiment agree and a
deviation by ofyou mev here and they are
not too bad but we started also looking
at different nuclear stability trends
and we noticed that for odd mass number
nuclei there is usually only one or
sometimes none stable isotopes per Z
whereas for even once there's quite a
few more and we're going to be now
linking up the stability of nuclei
versus what mode of decay they will take
in order to find a more stable
configuration we looked quickly at the
number of stable nuclei with even and
odd Z and noted that this these places
right here where there are no stable
nuclei correspond to technetium and
promethium there's no periodic table on
the back of this wall but behind my back
on the other wall there's that periodic
table where you can see the two elements
that are fairly light with no stable
isotopes that's what those correspond to
and the peaks correspond to what we call
magic numbers or numbers of protons or
neutrons where all available States some
energy are pretty much filled and this
goes for both protons and neutrons so
something with a magic number for both n
number of neutrons and Z number of
protons is going to be exceptionally
stable and we'll see how that's used as
a tool to synthesize the super-heavy
elements that we believe should exist
and finally we got into these mass
parabolas I found this to be a
particularly difficult concept to just
get mathematically if you remember we
wrote out the semi empirical mass
formula and said if you take the
derivative with respect to Z as we did
it you would get the most stable z for a
given a and we started graphing for a
equals 93 where naya beum is stable that
was just the one I had on the brain from
some failures in lab earlier this week
we started plotting where those nuclei
what is at the the relative masses are
for a fixed a so let's regenerate
that one right now because we were a
little fast at the end of last lecture
then I want to generate one for a equals
40 and you'll see something kind of
curious I'm going to leave this up here
for a sec if you notice for odd a nuclei
there's only one parabola whereas for
even a there are two why that is we're
gonna see when we look at the table of
nuclides but notice this nucleus right
here can decay by either positron
emission or beta emission to get to a
more stable form and there are many real
examples and I'm going to show you how
to find them so let's start off by going
back to the table of nuclides finding
niobium 93 just go up one more chunk and
there we are
Niobe M 93 is a stable isotope and if
you want to see where it came from you
can scroll down a little bit and see
it's possible parent nuclides right here
so let's say that niobium will draw
right there is stable we'll put it at
the bottom of this parabola and let's
work down in Z so we'll move to
zirconium zirconium 93 ostensively has a
very similar atomic mass but if you
remember that 93 amu is a rather poor
approximation for the actual mass of all
nuclei with a equals 93 in fact if you
look very closely at the atomic masses
zirconium 93 is 90 2.90 niobium 93 well
it looks like we have to go all the way
to another digit there 92.9 o6 you have
to go to like even more digits ninety
two point nine oh six three seventy five
ninety two point nine oh six four
seventy five so we go down in Z and
we've actually gone up in mass by looks
like the sixth or seventh digit in AMU
if we go up in mass we go down in
binding energy that tells us that
there's something that's less stable and
if you notice we went down by a very
smaller or Wien up by a very small
amount of mass notice also that it's
beta decay energy is really really small
ninety one kill electron volts so why
don't we put zirconium
just above and we note that that decay
will happen by data where the beta let's
say if we have an isotope with mass
number a protons Z and let's just call
it symbol question mark in beta decay we
have the same a will have a different Z
I'm gonna have to give these symbols
let's call this parent and we'll call
that daughter plus a beta plus an
electron antineutrino and what has to
happen to that Z in order for everything
to be conserved it's the same reaction
that we've gone here for I'm sorry for
their code iam so you'd have to have one
fewer proton to release one electron and
so that becomes same a but different Z
and this is the beta decay reaction
let's go back a little farther we'll
look at the possible parent nuclide for
anyone have a question
let's see which direction are we going
in Z here that goes to yet trium
actually looks like it's going down oh
yeah for beta decay I'm thinking I have
the reaction backwards sorry
need one more proton to account for the
extra negative charge you're right okay
yep I was thinking backwards because
we're now climbing up the decay chain in
reverse order so this could have come
from yttrium 93 with a much higher
energy of three MeV so let's put it reom
right here that gives a beta decay and
we'll just go one more back to strontium
93 has an even higher beta decay energy
so let's put that up here and let's take
a look at its mass real quick the mass
of strontium 93 92 point nine one four
AMU if we go back to niobium 93 now it's
noticeably different different to like
four significant digits instead of six
ninety two point nine one four versus
ninety two point nine oh six and so that
shows you that a tiny bit of mass and
AMU corresponds to a pretty significant
change in binding energy by that same
conversion factor that we've been using
everywhere nine thirty one point four
nine
AMU per big MeV
yeah per C squared
let's see yeah okay
so let's go now in the other direction
in the positron direction niobium can
also be made by electron capture from
molybdenum so let's put molybdenum right
here let's say that around half an Emmy
or what do we have here who was like
half an MeV like that
and let's see molybdenum 93 could have
been made by electron capture from
technetium 93 with an energy of three
point two oh one MeV even more extreme
and we'll go back one more because
there's a trend that I want you guys to
be able to see and this could have come
from electron capture from ruthenium I
think I may have said rubidium last time
but are you is ruthenium 93 and that 6.3
MeV something like that and this is
where we got to yesterday now I'd like
us to take a closer look at the decay
diagrams which tells us what possible
decay reactions can happen in each of
these reactions
so let's since we're right here on the
chart let's take a look at ruthenium
turning into technetium by what it says
electron capture so note that on the
table you can click on electron capture
and if it's highlighted then the decay
diagrams are known it's not known for
every isotope but for a lot of the ones
you'll be dealing with it is and you get
something I have to zoom out for a lot a
lot of different decays what I want you
to look at is this one here on the
bottom that I'll zoom into that should
be a little more visible so notice that
if you want to go down the entire 6.4
something MeV it usually proceeds by B+
or positron decay by either method and
as you go up the chain as these energy
differences get smaller look what
happens to the probability of getting
positron decay it shrinks lower and
lower and lower so they
a trend that the larger the decay energy
for this type of reaction the more
likely you're going to get positron
decay and in fact where we left off last
time is in order to get positron decay
the Q value of the reaction has to be at
least 1.0 to 2 MeV better known as at
least two times the rest mass of the
electron because in this case to
conserve charge and energy you shoot out
a positron and you also have to inject
an electron in order to conserve all the
charge going on here so there you have
it now let's look at the lower energy
decay of technetium to molybdenum which
had something like 3 MeV associated with
it so we'll click on technetium and its
energy is 3.2 MeV let's take a look at
its electron capture significantly
simpler already what do you notice about
these positron to electron capture
ratios anyone call it out indeed when
the energy of the decay goes down notice
that only these decays are allowed the
electron capture suddenly becomes much
more likely but notice that it does not
let you go directly from 3.2 mu v to 0
there's no allowable decay here so this
is probably a change of that's 3.2
that's 1.3 a little less than 2 MeV all
of a sudden electron capture becomes
much more likely but not at positron
decay is not disallowed yet so we can
say electron capture or positron decay
right there everyone with me so far so
let's go to the really low energy one
will click on molybdenum 93 and see how
it decays with an energy of 0.40 5 MeV
to niobium anyone want to guess what's
allowed
electron capture only there's not enough
energy for positron decay and indeed it
draws funny because there's a metastable
state but if you go scroll down here
there are two pathways allowed both of
which by electron capture decaying
diagrams quite a bit simpler so we leave
this one here by saying it can only
decay by electron capture any questions
on the odd a before we move on to the
even which is a little more interesting
cool okay let's move on to the even case
so for here I'm going to go back to the
overall picture of the table of nuclides
click on around where I think
potassium-40 is looks like I got there
and I want to point out one of these
features if you wanted to go under go
decay change and maintain the same mass
number that's diagonally from upper left
to lower right see how all the isotopes
here have a forty in front of them the
really interesting part is as you cross
this line you go from stable to unstable
to stable to unstable again the colors
here is dark blue represents stable and
dark gray represents long lifetimes of
over a hundred thousand years so this is
one of the reasons you find potassium-40
in the environment in fact point oh one
one percent of all potassium in you and
everything is potassium-40
it's what's known as a primordial
nuclide it's not stable but it's
half-life is so long that there's still
some left since the universe began or
whatever supernova that formed earth got
accumulated into the earth but notice it
can come from it can decay by a couple
of different methods so let's pick one
of those stable isotopes calcium for T
and put that as the bottom of the
parabola on this diagram
so we'll put calcium here and in a
relative sense we'll put a calcium point
right there for its total mass and it
could have come from beta decay from
potassium-40 or electron capture from
scandium 4040
it can beta-decay for about a 1.3 MeV so
potassium it's right here let's say it
could beta decay with about 1.3 MeV and
we'll trace potassium back a little bit
figure out where would it have come from
interesting doesn't tell us okay forget
that let's trace calcium back and say
there's scandium 40 and scandium 40 can
decay with Wow an enormous 14 point 3 2
MeV let's put that like here anyone want
to guess which mode electron capture or
positrons much more likely probably
positron let's take a look oh boy
another complicated one but the whole
way down positron positron positron for
all the most likely decays you won't
find a drawing too every single line I
believe that they know that at some
point drawing extra lines is futile and
they just all overlap each other so I
don't know exactly how the algorithm
works but it does draw up to some number
of possible decay chains if you want to
see every single one they are tabulated
in a very very long list down below I'm
never going to ask you to do something
with all of these because that would be
insane unless it's a relatively simple
decay like that has two or three
possibilities and let's see this could
have come from electron capture from
titanium forty with eleven point six
eight I'm easy Wow okay here
and there's titanium and let's go in the
other direction so I do know that
potassium-40
can decay into argon-40 so let's jump
there argon is a stable isotope too so
potassium-40 can decay into argon-40 by
electron capture okay good a more
respectable 1.50 5 MeV is positron decay
allowed yes why is that
/ 1.02 to mev yeah anyone had a question
no okay
so we've got kind of a kink in our math
parabola yeah that's correct yep so once
the Q value satisfied it is technically
possible
but if you had something with the decay
energy of like 1.0 to 3 MeV it would be
exceedingly unlikely so in fact we can
take a look at this this is I would say
is also going to be on the exceedingly
unlikely level and we can take a look so
if we look at the decay diagram we know
it makes positrons they're not even
really listed interesting because so
that process would not be allowed but
this one because that's about 1.5 MeV
should be allowed but since that branch
ratio or the probability of that
happening is already so low I wonder if
it even says yep beta ray with a max or
average energy of 482 point 8 MeV we're
gonna go over why that energy is so low
when we talk about decay next week with
a relative intensity of something with a
lot of zeros before the decimal place so
there you go like you said energies near
1.0 to 2 MeV slightly above it are
extremely unlikely but possible and
measurable cool and then let's see what
could have made argon-40 could have been
beta decay from chlorine 40 so chlorine
maybe was here and I don't think I have
to draw any more so we've got an
funny-looking parabola with a kink in it
because really you have two bass
parabolas overlapping I'm gonna go back
to the screen so that the diagram from
the notes makes a little more sense what
we've kind of traced out here is that
there's two overlapping parabolas here
there's the one with the what is it the
odd Z and the even Z so there you go
just like the one on here which i think
is for a different mass number yep 102
we get the same kind of behavior
where things will mostly follow the
lower-mass parabola but sometimes if
something gets stuck here it can go
either way to get more stable so I want
to stop here for new stuff because this
is precisely where I thought we'd be at
the end of the week and in the next half
an hour I'd like to open it up to
questions or working things out together
on the board or anything else you might
have had yeah sure
it's going to go in whatever when
whatever way makes it more stable so
you're never going to have a nucleus is
going to spontaneously gain mass in
order to get to a different path you can
only go down on the mass axis but let's
say you happen to be starting here at
potassium-40
you can go down via either mechanism to
the next mass parabola down
that's quite if you're at argon you're
stuck and in fact if you want to take a
look what do I mean scientifically by
stuck I mean stable argon-40 is a stable
nucleus that comprises ninety nine point
six percent of the argon so that's what
I mean by stock is stable and if we look
at the rest of the table of nuclides for
similar looking places so let's hunt
near potassium-40 so notice potassium-40
right here has got stable isotopes to
the upper left and the lower right if we
look back over here manganese 54 same
deal it's got a stable isotope to the
upper left and a stable one to the lower
right how much you want to bet that when
we click on manganese 54 it's got two
possible parent new clients I'm sorry
two possible decay math methods so let's
take a look manganese 54 can either
electron capture and positron decay to
chromium 54 or beta decay to iron 54
let's take a look at one more to hammer
the point home and I think that'll
probably be enough cobalt 58 right near
nickel 58 and iron 58 interesting that
one's not allowed unless there's more
down here so you can electron capture to
iron 58 but there's no allowed decay to
what was it nickel 58 okay let's look
for more chlorine 36 has argon and
sulfur on either side there it is
beta-decay and electron capture and how
much you want to bet there's basically
never a positron here but basically not
actually never so you get a positron
0.01 percent of the time and electron
capture one point eight nine percent of
the time where's the other 98 and change
percent right here in the beta decay so
in this case chlorine 36 will
preferentially beta decay if you also
notice it's a let's see you don't know
if that actually matters so but I'm
gonna say it's more likely to beta decay
so when you sum these up you get a
hundred percent of the possible to case
let's see how many energy levels there
are there too hopefully not too many
that qualifies as not too many yeah John
they'll be due to those as well as some
other processes which we're going to
cover on decay but if you notice I've
been giving you a lot of flash-forwards
in this class we've introduced
cross-sections as a thing that a
proportionality constant between
interaction probabilities we're going to
hit them hard later I've also been kind
of introducing or flash forwarding
different methods of decay so there's
also alpha decay
there's also isomeric transition or
gamma emission
there's also spontaneous fission this is
the whole basis behind how fission can
get working without some sort of
kick-starting elements so maybe now's a
good time to show you let's go to
uranium-235 and see how it decays a de
ganar D undergoes alpha decay de thorium
231 most of the time and if you look how
it's no it's not terrible we can make
sense of this it also undergoes SF which
stands for a spontaneous fission so one
out of every seven Lords it you know
seven out of every billion times it will
just spontaneously fizz into two fission
products and this is why if you put
enough uranium-235 together in one place
you can make a critical reactor in
reality you don't tend to want to put
enough u-235 together to just
spontaneously go critical we use other
isotopes as Kickstarter's for example
californium I think it's two fifty-two
let's take a quick look there we go
californium 252 undergo spontaneous
fission three percent of the time it's
even heavier even more unstable so there
is a reactor called high fer or the high
flux isotope reactor at Oak Ridge
National Lab one of its main outputs is
californium Kickstarter's for reactors
so to get things going you put a little
bit of californium in as a gigantic
neutron source and then you don't really
need it anymore once it gets going so
it's one of the safer ways of starting
up a reactor is put in a crazy neutron
source and then once it gets going take
it out or leave it in and burn it I'm
not actually sure which one they do yep
it is when we get to now is a good time
to introduce the super-heavy element
since you asked so a lot of these older
elements were named after all actually
this is kind of a hobby of mine
so I don't know if you guys saw the
periodic table outside
I collect elements because if you're
gonna collect something you might as
well collect everything that everything
else is made of it's the same reason I
went into nuclear energy
I started off course 6 or 6/1
specifically electrical and I was like
well I could be designing like the next
screen for a cell phone or we could
solve the energy problem which is the
problem all others are based off of so
my whole life theme has been go to the
source that's why I came here in high
school and never left that's why I
declared course 22 that's why I collect
elements and probably is the reason for
many other things which only a
psychiatrist could diagnose but let's
look at some of the other elements for
example yttrium I think it has an
isotope 40 anyone know no it doesn't
have a 40 what about a 50 60 hundred
whatever at least it knew that why was
you a trio anyone know where this is
coming from 89 seems high oh my god
you're right okay gotcha you work with
it awesome
anyone know what this is all about get
trium there's a town called Iturbi in
sweden where large deposits of yttrium
and ytterbium or YB tend to be found or
DB name for dubnium so let's say the
really basic elements tend to come from
Latin F F stands for iron which actually
stands for theorem led is plumbum gold
as Orem silver AG is argenteum I don't
know if I'm saying that right
I never took Latin and I've never heard
it spoken of course and then a lot of
the heavier and heavier elements as we
go our being named for more and more
famous scientists or places where they
tend to be made like dB I'm gonna guess
264 a mass there oh nice for a doob nah
in Russia that has got one of the few
gigantic
for heavy element colliders where
they're constantly synthesizing and
characterizing these super-heavy
elements so finally they said you know
what they've made enough of these in
Dubna let's name one of the elements
after them or SG seaborgium for glenn
seaborg or n o nobelium for Alfred Nobel
yep
ah do they intersect I've never seen a
case where they intersect that would
make for a crazy situation indeed
however part of what the homework
assignments about is to derive an
analytical form for a mass parabola and
then check the data to see how well it
works so for any cases where you have an
even mass number and you have either odd
odd or even even nuclei you can check
those equations analytically to see if
they'll intersect
so the top parabola for potassium-40
let's take a quick look at how many
protons and neutrons it has potassium
has a proton number of 19 which means it
has a neutron number of 21 so the top
parabola is odd n and odd Z where the
bottom one is even N and even C whereas
for odd mass number nuclei it has to be
either odd even or even odd else it
would be even which is a funny sentence
when you say it all out loud yeah so
that's the idea here is that notice that
the even even parabola tends to be
further down all those nuclear magic
numbers - 8 20 28 I'm not going to quote
the rest those little ones I know all
even numbers so any other questions on
these math problems before we launch
into super heavy elements yep uh-huh
analytically or experimentally which
question so analytically analytically
there should be some isotope of well not
potassium that wouldn't be allowed so in
this case the the stable element
positions have got to kind of switch off
shouldn't they so if that's potassium 40
that would still have to be potassium
you don't really have another choice
there isn't really a position there is
there analytically that's the
interesting thing is that you can either
be odd odd or even even for an even mass
number but you can't just take off one
Neutron from potassium-40 and then
you've got potassium 39 then you're on a
different mass number or if you exchange
a proton and a neutron which you pretty
much do in either of these directions
there's no way to get straight down here
yep
fraud what proof sorry yeah let's go
back to that slide just to make sure you
mean the pairing term in the semi
empirical mass formula yeah yeah
so for aw dog nuclei and D Delta is
negative which means lower binding
energy which means higher mass and
that's why we see it bump up on the mass
right here yep and you have a second
part of the question
Oh
ah we can actually relate so we can
relate the binding energy to the mass
and the mass parabola analytically
because the binding energy is equal to Z
times protons plus n times mass of
neutron minus the actual mass of that
same nucleus a comma Z so they're
actually directly related just
negatively so something with a higher
mass is going to have a low binding
energy which means it's less bound and
less stable and indeed the further up
the mass scale we go the higher those
beta or electron capture or positron
energies are and there's another thing
you can check to which is the half-life
half-life is what we'll be talking about
on Tuesday it's how long before an
average amount of a substance has
undergone radioactive decay so let's
look at some of these isotopes and start
looking at half-life trends as another
measure of stability so potassium-40 has
an exceptionally long half-life so it's
relatively stable
let's take a look not at either the
stable isotopes but let's go up the mass
parabola chain in one direction calcium
for T scandium-46 can diem for T
scandium 45 less than a second and it's
got quite a high decay energy by
whatever method you want to use let's go
up to titanium for T anyone want to
guess is eating the half-life is gonna
go up or down let's see if the half-life
goes down we know the decay energy goes
up indeed half-life goes down from 182
milliseconds to 50 milliseconds and
let's say titanium forty could have come
from Wow two proton decay from cr.42
with a half-life of 350 nano seconds so
as we go up the mass ladder and down the
stability ladder the half-life decreases
which kind of follows intuitively
something that's exceptional
Stables should have a half-life of
infinity and something that's
exceptionally unstable should just blow
apart instantly like remember the first
week of class we talked about helium for
grabbing a neutron becoming helium 5 and
instantaneously going back to helium 4
if you look at helium 5 it's half-life
is measured in MeV or 7 times 10 to the
minus seventh femtoseconds so if helium
4 absorbs a neutron it simply doesn't
want it and gets rid of it in ten to the
minus seven femtoseconds which would
tell us that it's exceptionally unstable
so I hope that's a long-winded answer to
that question but what does it mean to
go to be going up in the mass levels any
other questions on mass parabolas or the
liquid drop model or stability in
general yes
so if you're changing one neutron to a
proton in each case you're switching
back and forth from the odd odd to the
even even mass parabolas so if I were to
redraw these dots more to scale this
would have to be on the odd odd and oh
let me draw them a little better yep
that's on the odd odd and that's on the
even even yeah so excuse my poor drawing
skills but if you're switching one
proton to a neutron or vice versa by
definition you're jumping back and forth
between these parabolas that's a good
question for clarification you had a
question too
[Music]
the semi-empirical I'm sorry the semi
empirical mass formula is a good way to
get an analytical guess at most of them
if you want an exact answer always use
the actual binding energy I would not
say it's used much now except well
that's gonna be one of your homework
questions is this formula predicts that
as you get heavier and heavier and
heavier nuclei should just continuously
get less stable and that was as of when
this was derived let's say decades ago
we now know something different is
happening so if you look at the table of
nuclides you can sort of see some swells
in the number of black pixels until it
cuts off and this region actually where
we think super-heavy elements happen I
want to jump to the actual table of
nuclides which I'll say is our snapshot
of knowledge today and go all the way to
the top and our knowledge kind of cuts
off at these elements which are for now
temporarily named in a very uncreated
way we don't even know anything about
them uun probably going to have a proton
number of what 110 I don't know what the
prefixes are but you you you would be on
one one one probably has 111 protons
beyond here off the screen or probably
up into the next room it's predicted
that once you approach the next magic
number in nuclei there should be an
island of stability where and it may not
necessarily be totally stable but the
half-life should go up again and we
should be able to synthesize super-heavy
matter and if you actually graph Neutron
number versus half-life so notice how we
were looking at half-life as a measure
of stability it starts to go up then
comes down and then to the extent of our
knowledge it is going back up again to
the next predicted magic number so what
we think should be happening is
half-life should be continuously going
up and yeah you had a question
well whatever you want it's gonna be it
should be dense as all heck because
nuclear matters quite a bit denser than
ordinary matter and quite a bit as quite
an understatement
so what would you do with super heavy
matter a lot of it could be used to
probe the structure of matter there's a
lot about how the nucleus is constructed
that we don't know and beyond the scope
of this course would also be an
understatement
there's folks that are making their
careers now and figuring out what are
the forces between nucleons why do
things spontaneously fizz at the rates
that they do you'll even hit a little
bit of this in 22:02
when you can calculate the rough
half-life for alpha decay using quantum
tunneling through the potential barrier
in a nucleus and so the more nuclei we
have to mess around with the more data
and real examples we have to study but
practical applications well I could
imagine we might find something denser
than osmium osmium right now is a
density of about 22 grams per cubic
centimeter this stuff zirconium
it's about 6.9 or so Steel's like eight
LEDs like eleven Mercury's like nineteen
via any of you ever played with liquid
mercury before yeah this is a don't try
this at home kids kind of moment my
grandfather happened to be a dentist so
we happen to have a lot of mercury to
mess around with and it's like
unintuitive ly heavy it's unbelievable a
one-pound jar is about that big I think
would be cool if we could time something
even denser and then really really dense
matter happens to make really really
good photon shields gamma seen on the
Star Trek thing I mean this in the
actual nuclear physics sense is the best
way to stop gamma rays for gamma
shielding is just put more matter in
front of it and if we find a denser
state of matter that's earth stable you
then have a smaller gamma shield so
there are practical applications to in
radiation shielding they also might make
awesome nuclear fuel because you better
believe they're gonna fizz like crazy so
who knows maybe we can I don't think
that would be cost-effective but it
would probably work so the way they're
doing this is actually slamming calcium
48 nuclei
into other super-heavy elements that
have exceptionally long half-lives so if
you can't read what the screen says this
here is berkelium for berkeley with
proton number 97 mass number 249 let's
take a look at EK 249 which happens to
be way beyond uranium so it's definitely
not a stable isotope but it has a
half-life of 320 days that means you can
make a bunch of it chemically separated
make it into a target and fire calcium
48 nuclei into it anyone want to guess
why do we use calcium 48 and I'll give
you a hint and write the proton number
for calcium the isotope that we use it's
calcium 28 Coliseum 48 anyone want to
take a guess why start here why not just
smash to berkelium Xin to each other
calcium 48 happens to be exceptionally
stable because it's got two magic
numbers it's proton number is twenty one
of those peaks of stability and it's
Neutron numbers 28 so start with
something super stable something with a
lot more binding energy to begin with
and you maximize your chance of making
something with more binding energy that
won't just spontaneously disappear so
there are reasons calcium 48 was chosen
and not something heavier or lighter if
we go back to that article you can see
what happens here is you make some
element 117 which has yet to be made and
it undergoes alpha decay until it
reaches some rather stable you know 17
seconds that's pretty exceptional and if
you notice the trends here as you decay
the alpha energy steadily goes down and
the half-life steadily goes up and so
what you do is you make an super
super-heavy element hoping that it will
decay and rest in one of these islands
of stability beyond the magic numbers
that we know right now which I thought
this was super cool because this is
actually how
opening now like new elements are made I
think we've been seeing one a year or so
for the past few years on average there
might have been a year when there was
more than one announced recently there's
only a few places in the world doing
them but you can start to already with
two weeks of 2201 you can start to get a
handle for why do they use the nuclei
they do and then what sort of things are
you looking for decays with lower and
lower energy mean you're already
starting to gets less steep on whatever
imaginary mass parabola don't quite know
how to draw this one because it's beyond
anything we know and as the half-lives
keep going up you can tell that it's
reaching a measure of stability however
to get you started on the homework for
the open ended problem I think I'll
bring it up right now so you guys can
take a look so let's go to the stellar
site
hopefully it doesn't call me good
at the problem set 2 this is the way I
know that everyone's seen the pset 7
days before it's due cuz I'm gonna put
it up on the screen so you can see it
all the way at the end predicting the
island of stability does the semi
empirical mass formula predict the
island of stability well let's start you
off with the easier part of the question
which is yes or no and I'm gonna leave
you to the why and the how if we graph
binding energy per nucleon versus mass
number the semi empirical mass formula
predicts something like this what
happens as we go beyond the realm of
known mass numbers anyone how should I
extend this curve
would you say Alex just keep going yeah
does this predict an island of stability
I don't think so
so that's one of the few questions I'm
asking you in this homework and it's up
to you guys use your creativity again
this is an open-ended problem I'm not
looking for a specific answer I want to
see how you think and how you would
change this formula to account and
actually predict the island of stability
while still satisfying the mostly
correct predictions from the elements we
know so sorry go ahead
well yaar you're on the right track if
you wanna make if you want to show
stability you'd want it to maybe have a
higher value right here higher binding
energy per nucleon would correspond to a
lower mass which would correspond to
higher stability so how would you
predict this island of stability and
then more specifically how would you
reconcile the misty inaccuracies in the
semi empirical mass formula because we
know it doesn't work very well for all
cases there are some cases like right
around here where it works great and
there's some like right here and right
here where it really doesn't and get
things wrong by like ten MeV which is
pretty significant you know that's like
four digits on the mass scale like the
fourth decimal place that's huge to a
nuclear engineer so that's something to
get thinking about and remember I did
tell you that there will be some
open-ended problems I'm gonna mark them
as open-ended so you actually know we're
not looking for a right or wrong answer
this is one of those kinds of things
where we want to see how you think and
what do you think is missing there's
other hard problems where we give you
the answer because I'm not interested in
you deriving some explainin expression
and getting it right I'm interested in
the derivation process what are the
steps you choose what sort of
assumptions do you make what sort of
terms can you neglect and say that's in
the ninth decimal place I'm going to
forget it so in this case we give you
the answer because we're going to grade
you on the process
and you can use the answer to check your
process and see if you're on the right
track or not for the skill building
questions we actually do want you to
come up with some sort of an answer like
explaining the terms in the semi
empirical mass formula or modifying an
equation to calculate something else we
will be looking for a right answer there
but those are questions to make sure
that you get the basics of the material
if you can answer all of the questions
in the first half of these P sets fairly
quickly let's say in three or four hours
you're totally on the right track the
hard ones is because this is MIT and we
want you to think beyond just knowing
what's in the Turner book or the Yip
book like I said you guys are the
leaders of this field so any other
questions on instability in general yes
you say
correct so that would be even N and even
Z are on N and odd Z like in the reading
and like on these mass parabolas yep any
other questions yes
there's a few roots so the question was
is the only is the only reason people
think they'll be super heavy elements
because the mass increases right so in
this case the the mass will always are
you talking about now the total mass or
okay we have a few things to go on so
all there are a number of different
aspects of nuclear stability that are
all pointing to the same conclusion one
of them you can see on this graph here
if you look at the alpha decay half-life
as a function of Neutron number it
doesn't just increase or decrease
monotonically it swells up and down and
it reaches a relative maximum near
certain magic numbers we can confirm
that with the lower mass nuclei it
doesn't work for really low mass because
tiny things don't tend to go under
undergo alpha decay but there are
patterns that were simply recognizing
and saying well if this is the next
magic number it should continue to
increase and I should mention to this
scale is logarithmic so the top right
here is like 10 to the 4 seconds just so
you know there are 86,400 seconds in
what is it a day and 3 times 10 to the 7
seconds in a year so if this graph let's
say for Z 111 were to continue on its
track it should reach like 10 to the 9
or 10 to the 10 which could be like
hundred year lifetimes or 100 year
half-lives which means definitely you
can chemically separate them and do
things with them I don't know if they
would be safe enough to deal with but we
also don't really know what's going to
happen you can see that there is some
uncertainty and things don't always
follow the trend even the error bars are
outside the dashed lines but so we have
this to go on we have the alpha decay
half-life we also have the alpha decay
energy as you approach an island of
stability something that's more stable
won't give off as much kinetic energy to
its alpha particle there's also for the
ones that you can actually measure that
live long enough you can measure their
mass-to-charge ratio and actually get a
good picture of their actual mass so we
would expect the mass defect to follow a
certain trend as we go up the mass is
always going to increase if you add more
nucleons it's going to increase but the
mass defect which is the real mass minus
the atomic number mass if stability were
to increase do you think the mass defect
would increase or decrease with more
stability let's take a quick look at
this if a were to stay the same a
shrinking real mass and remember lower
mass means more stability would mean a
higher or a lower mass defect I mean a
lower mass defect or a lower excess mass
as you'd call it so in this case you
would expect the mass of the nucleus to
be smaller than its a if it was going
more stable and all of these trends work
in the same direction which is saying
okay so we have the Alpha energy we have
the mass defect we have the half-life
all pointing to the same thing that
something should be more stable and we
have some patterns to go on but our
understandings kind of incomplete so yep
whoo good question
so the question is if super-heavy
elements exist do they exist out there
in space I think there would be a couple
places they would exist the source of
most of the elements beyond iron is
supernovas where a regular old fusion
doesn't cut it anymore when you hit the
maximum of this binding energy per
nucleon curve you're at about iron-56
that's why stars tend to form a core of
iron before it goes really bad in
whatever way it does for a star there
are multiple ways when you get a
supernova you have an insane explosion
and the core gets compressed from the
outside
forcing fusion of heavy elements to
happen that's because you're putting in
extra kinetic energy so it's like you
have an endothermic reaction where if Q
is less than zero how do you make that
reaction happen add kinetic energy which
can come from a tremendous explosion
outside of the outer regions of the star
so who's to say that some of these
super-heavy elements aren't formed in
supernovas I think they would be but
would they actually make it out to be
part of earth and then let's say live
the five billion years that Art's been
around we don't know if their half-lives
are long enough there very well may have
been some five billion years ago or when
the supernova was made but we haven't
detected any here on earth so we know
that they're not five billion years
stable rather I wouldn't even need to
say we know that but we have a pretty
good idea
that's a great question is like are they
naturally made probably yeah any other
questions I like these outside the
material ones we can take things beyond
our known universe start to explain them
you